Donald Trump flew all the way to the
French countryside to a world war one
Cemetery in honor of the troops who
fought in that war although he didn't
quite make it
he made it to a hotel in Paris and
ultimately called off his participation
in the event because it was raining and
instead he watched television Winston
Churchill's grandson Nicholas Soames
who's a member of the British Parliament
blasted Trump as pathetic and inadequate
for failing to show up this is
disrespectful to the troops to their
families Trump said he'd be the best on
the military that's not happening this
is disrespectful to every American
taxpayer who bears the cost of this trip
for Trump to sit around watching
television and tweeting here are German
and French leaders Angela Merkel and
Emmanuel macron both apparently able to
brave the brutal reign and stand there
for a few minutes between limo rides
rain not something that would stop Trump
from golfing however here's a picture of
Donald Trump playing golf in the rain
that certainly didn't seem to deter him
there but honoring the troops after
traveling all the way to Europe in the
rain apparently just too much to ask
is there any bigger snowflake than this
guy 93 year old Queen Elizabeth the
second had no problem whatsoever making
it out to all of the events of the day
and it's really not at all surprising
when you think back to Trump being the
guy who got a deferment out of Vietnam
because his foot hurt later he couldn't
remember which foot it was maybe it was
both of them who even knows who even
really cares right and if you want a
manly president this is not something I
care about okay but there are many Trump
supporters who are all about Obama was
bata and Trump is alpha by your own
standards you've got to be missing Obama
at this point right here is President
Bhama greeting supporters in the rain
here he is giving a speech with no
umbrella in the rain here's President
Obama honoring fallen soldiers in the
rain with no umbrella mind you and I
could go on and imagine for a second
what would right-wingers have done if
President Obama had done this can you
even imagine because it would have been
a far bigger scandal than the time Obama
chose the wrong mustard for the cuisine
he was eating it would be worse than the
time Obama wore a tan suit on a day when
he was scheduled to deal with serious
issues
Trump bragged remember that he would
have run into the high school in
parkland Florida of Marjorie Stoneham
Douglass High School during that mass
shooting if only he had been there and
he can't even honor the troops in the
rain and were supposed to believe he
would have run into a building with an
active shooter to defend high schoolers
can anybody answer me this question Pat
what's more disrespectful kneeling
during the national anthem before a
football game or refusing to go out in
the rain after flying to Europe on a
trip meant to honor the troops because
it's sprinkling and you might get wet
well you know me I would certainly say
the latter but I do have the explainer
for this and it's Trump's hair he can't
afford to get that thing wet now you
could say that the man could use an
umbrella but we have video evidence
showing that he actually doesn't know
how to close the umbrella so there's no
way he could have possibly made this
event I mean just the hairstyle alone
that meerkat for a hairstyle not gonna
allow him to do it we're going to get to
the geopolitical implications of this
but this guy is pathetic he mocked John
McCain for being captured in the
military he says that he made sacrifices
just like gold star families have done
and the guy doesn't go out in the rain
he respects dictators and himself period
that is it and I'm getting lots of
emails from people saying David is it
even really necessary for the president
to go to Europe
to commemorate a hundred years of the
end of World War one like it's not even
clear that his presence was necessary
you can have that debate I agree that
Trump's presence wasn't necessary but
this event is actually a pretty big deal
in the UK and in Europe and the
important thing here is that if you
decide to go and then you actually make
it there go to the event don't sit in
your hotel room watching TV because it's
raining while a 93 year old queen is
able to make it out there this is the
most beta of beta totally triggered
snowflake and it's an absolute
embarrassment to this country and we're
gonna be talking about that extensively
later today I've got a piece I'm
planning for you tomorrow about how
world leaders are just sick of Trump's
BS and they're making it clear that
they're sick of Trump's BS this is sort
of it's it's a story that is about a
micro issue that's going on but it
actually is emblematic of so much of
what's wrong with this guy and we're
gonna be talking about it okay let's get
to an update on the Jim Acosta story Jim
Acosta is a CNN reporter he asked
questions of Donald Trump which I know
to many of you will not come as a shock
since that's what many reporters do and
Donald Trump didn't like the questions
and during this question-and-answer
period there was an incident where a
White House intern started to try to
physically remove the microphone from
Jim Acosta while Trump and Acosta were
arguing Acosta's arm got tangled up with
the interns here's the original clip
that started all of this a long way that
that's not an evasion honestly I think
you should let me run the country you
run CNN or and if you did it well your
ratings let me ask you if I miss
president for me if I may
are you worried that's enough that's one
of the other folks that's enough pardon
me ma'am
mr. president that's enough this
president I had one of these I may ask
you on on the Russia investigation are
you concerned that that you may have not
concerned about anything with you may
have an investigation because it's a
hoax are you that's enough put down the
mic mr. president are you worried about
indictments coming down in this
investigation
mr. president I tell you what CNN should
be ashamed of itself having you working
for them you are a rude terrible person
yeah so then after this the story from
the White House became we are getting
rid of Jim Acosta from these briefings
because he put his hands on a woman and
then video was released which was
apparently edited in a way to make it
seem as though the moment where the arms
get tangled between Acosta and the
intern was a moment of Jim Acosta being
violent in some way with this intern and
we reported on the video when it first
came out it appeared quite a bit as
though there was something up with it
and it seems that it was sort of a
combination of speeding up the moment
where Jim Acosta zarm goes in downward
direction with potentially even removing
some frames to make that downward motion
look sort of more aggressive and we now
have an interview that Trump adviser
Kellyanne Conway gave on Fox News Sunday
where she admits that this video was
indeed edited but she called it not
edited not altered not doctored simply
sped up and her language here is
completely Orwellian and I'm gonna play
it for you and then we'll talk about it
take a look this brings me to my final
subject which is the now infamous
confrontation with Jim Acosta at that
news conference as you know I have been
very critical of a Kostas behavior
myself but I want to ask you about two
responses by the White House first to
tweet a video that was clearly altered
to make it look like it was more of a
physical confrontation than it really
was although I do think it wasn't
ah Priya and second - pull Acosta's pass
to get into the white house and to
threaten to do that to other reporters
well Chris first of all what do you mean
by edited or as others are saying quote
doctored video he either put his hands
on her and grabbed the mic back or he
did not and he clearly did no he did but
the video was altered and their experts
who have looked it up to make it look
pardon oh well that's not altered that's
sped up they do it all the time and
sports to see if there's actually a
first down or a touchdown so I don't I
have to disagree with the I think
overall description listen I watch a lot
of sports on TV has she ever seen sports
on TV in sports you do slow motion to
see what happened you don't do fast
motion like have you ever seen referees
Pat say you know we really didn't get a
clear look at that can you show us a
replay in 2x speed so that we can really
figure out what's going on like that
this is one of the dumbest explanations
so far the only thing I can think of is
like on a highlight reel if you're
showing a football player making a 90
yard run maybe you'll speed that up
because the clip takes a little bit of
time but if you're trying to focus in on
something like I don't know a fumble or
whether a runner was safer out at the
plate you want to slow that down so the
public can actually get a look at what
happened yeah the idea that you would
speed something up to ascertain what
actually took place is ridiculous and of
course this is part of the words have no
meaning thing anymore Kellyanne Conway
of the Bowling Green massacre which
didn't exist of alternative fact which
of course it's sort of binary something
either is a fact or it is not in fact it
was sped up at a particular moment to
create a different perception of what it
is that took place period the idea that
changing the speed of a video is
irrelevant because it's just the
playback speed is ridiculous imagine
your honor there's no way I was speeding
check out this video of me driving at
the time right before I was pulled over
look at how slowly I'm moving well that
video has clearly been altered no your
honor it's
not been altered I've simply slowed the
video down well yet what's at issue is
how fast you were driving so slowing the
video down is an alteration that's
what's at issue here they can't be
trusted to tell the truth about anything
like stupid things irrelevant things
important things they they can't be
relied upon to give us the truth about
anything and in the end why not just say
you know what the video was altered we
regret sharing an altered video put
together by a conspiracy website but we
believe that Jim Acosta's behavior is
what was inappropriate it's not the
speed at which he chopped a female
interns arm we simply don't want him
around because we think that his
presence is toxic like Pat why not just
save that you don't need doctored video
to defend your decision some people are
gonna be happy with your decision to
kick them out others are going to say
let's file a lawsuit which is exactly
what CNN has done and we'll talk about
tomorrow but it's not that the video is
even necessary for them to write what
they want oh you can totally concede
that the video was altered and still try
to feign the moral high ground in that
exchange because they could still say
that Jim Acosta acted inappropriately
and that's not the demeanor that you
expect from the White House press corps
you can go in that direction but Kelly
and Conway she has to stick to it
doubling down time and again with just
absolute and total fabrications welcome
to the show and what what a show we have
for you today let's start with
projection and voting the level at which
the right is projecting their actions
onto the left has really come to a head
on the topic of this recent Florida
election and subsequent recount that is
going on it is now being reported that a
heavily Republican County in Florida has
allowed some residents wait for it to
vote by email which you might be
wondering about and yes indeed
that is against the law I'm gonna reset
the entire story for you so that we all
sort of have all of this
same information on which to base our
analysis so let's go back a couple of
years four years now the right has been
saying we need voter ID we need all
sorts of other voter suppression
policies because of voter fraud mostly
perpetrated by the left they said people
are voting for others people are voting
twice dead people are voting not really
the live people are going and saying
they are people who have actually died
the reality is that that's not a problem
okay there's been a huge meta-analysis
by the brennan center for justice which
found that there were in something like
1.3 billion ballots cast around 30
individual instances of fraud over like
a 14 year period or something like that
i mean the numbers were just
infinitesimally small so we cut to last
week the florida elections happen it's
very close in the senate race it's very
close in the gubernatorial race and you
see on election night republicans in the
lead of rick scott in the senate and ron
DeSantis apparently winning on election
night we then find out that there are a
whole bunch of ballots which simply
haven't been counted many of them found
at a mail handling facility in a liberal
part of the state miami-dade county
irregularities in Broward County another
one of the three sort of big blue
counties of Florida that are responsible
for a lot of the Democratic votes in
these elections we've got questionable
Val 'its that voting machines
disqualified that we need to look at by
hand to really get a final tally
Republicans immediately say oh this is
voter fraud by Democrats they're sort of
implying that Democrats dropped off bags
of ballots after the election was over
at a mail facility and of course there's
no evidence of foul play or fraud and if
Democrats had a plan of swinging the
election with the bags of paper ballots
they would have number one gotten them
in before Election Day actually took
place and number two they probably
wouldn't have dropped them off in a
liberal area
since that would attract exactly this
type of attention so if Democrats are
trying to steal the election with paper
ballots dropped off late in a blue area
they are really doing something very
stupid by way of are in the hopes of
swinging the election fraudulently so
over the last few days we've had
Republicans doing everything they can to
oppose the recounts Donald Trump
claiming voter fraud with no evidence
Sean Hannity on Fox News saying someone
should go to jail for this and we've now
learned that in a very Republican County
in Florida this is Bay County where in
2016 Donald Trump had 71 percent of the
vote in the presidential election the
election supervisor in Bay County his
name's Marc Anderson he has admitted
he's not even denying that he has
allowed people to vote by email this is
against the law this is not allowed now
you can argue we should have voting by
email in the United States we should
have electronic voting or you could
argue that we shouldn't but what you
can't argue is that we don't so this is
against the law this is a form of
fraudulent voting that the election
supervisor has admitted to why did this
happen they say that it's because of the
hurricane but it's just not adding up
because after the hurricane on October
10th rick Scott who is not only the
senator elect in Florida he's also the
governor he put out an executive order
saying we're gonna extend early voting
we're going to add early voting
locations but no votes can be submitted
by email or fax like he specifically
addressed that issue and people were
allowed by the election supervisor to
scan or take pictures of their ballots
and email them in and the election
supervisor is defending it by saying we
are simply taking care of voters Pat
what about taking care of voters by
making it easier to vote what about
taking care of voters by expanding
voting locations or early voting not
because of a hurricane but just because
it's the right thing to do or not
purging voter rolls no they don't do any
of that stuff
now they want to help voters by allowing
a Republican County to vote by email
which is against the law
yes sounds to me like voter fraud and I
estimate that anywhere from three to
five million people voted illegally my
thought is that we have to put together
a voter integrity Commission to really
get down to the bottom of the bottom of
this because Democrats should have won
both of these races it makes more sense
here than it did after the 2016 election
that's for sure because these are
hundreds of instances of what Donald
Trump claimed three to five million
people did in 2016
without any actual evidence and just as
I mean while we're talking about Trump
Trump said he would prosecute all
election fraud voting by email is a form
of election fraud is it going to be
prosecuted
I guess Rick Scott was right there
actually was a voter fraud problem here
but not in miami-dade County not in
Broward County in heavily Republican Bay
County you cannot write this stuff I
know that I've said this before Pat that
the most embarrassing and ignorant thing
that Trump has done on the national
stage just happened and then a week goes
by and then once again I say okay now
Trump has done the most embarrassing
thing and usually it's true because we
think we've hit the top or sometimes
it's rock bottom and then he does some
something worse he might undo outdo
himself in the future indefinitely and
that is where we are today there's a
stunning report in france's newspaper
Lamond which alleges that donald trump
did two mind-blowing things in april so
in april donald trump met with the
leaders of Lithuania Estonia and Latvia
now if you hear those three countries
and think oh there's something about
those three countries as a group yes
they're called the Baltic states these
are three countries in Northern Europe
that are now independent countries on
the Baltic Sea previously subject to
USSR rule I guess we could call it I was
in one of those countries over the
summer Estonia absolutely beautiful
place fantastic people amazing
architecture
culture great food those three countries
are the Baltic countries Donald Trump
confuse them in front of their leaders
with the Balkans
now the Balkans are not the Baltic
countries the Balkans are in a different
part of Europe about a thousand miles
away
they include Albania Bulgaria Bosnia and
Herzegovina Kosovo Macedonia Montenegro
they ended up in their current state
after the early 90s breakup of
Yugoslavia and geographically you could
say that the the the peninsula the
Balkan Peninsula includes pieces of some
other countries as well Donald Trump
confused the Baltics and the Balkans and
then he said something that made
absolutely no sense and according to
this report in in Newsweek the leaders
of the three Baltic states were just
sort of confused looking around like
what the hell is this guy talking about
and then they realized that Trump thinks
that they are from the Balkans not the
Baltics and what Trump said was that
they are responsible for starting wars
that led to the breakup of Yugoslavia in
1991 can you imagine you are the
president of Estonia or Latvia you know
whichever one of these countries you are
you've come out of the USSR you've
rebuilt the country your country is a
sort of beacon of success in a region
that has had many political and economic
problems in Estonia one of the most
technologically advanced democracies in
the world you get invited to the White
House Wow President of the United States
you fly halfway around the world and the
president says to you you did a bad
thing when you started that war that
broke up Yugoslavia and then you realize
the guy has no idea where you're from an
absolute and total embarrassment and Pat
this is what you get when you combine
ignorant and anti intellectualism with a
political movement that sees that as a
virtue and enshrines ignorant Anton
fools as leaders you get the leaders of
Estonia Latvia and Lithuania saying what
the hell is the president talking about
right now and let's remember it's been
the u.s. that has been starting the wars
in recent memory namely the war in Iraq
but yeah Trump just is not very good
with geography he referred to Namibia
the country in Africa as nambia he
doesn't understand the differences
between the United Kingdom and Great
Britain in England he thinks those
things are interchangeable they're all
the same yeah you should just study up I
think that's what it comes down to the
right loves to slam the left for
language policing but they do their own
language policing and then the right
likes to slam the left for identity
politics but then you realize wait a
second the entire Trump is movement the
alt-right these are identity movements
and they happen to be horrible identity
movements and then the right likes to
slam the left for virtue signaling which
they do just as much if not more of
accept with horrible virtues like those
of dogmatic religious belief and anti
education ideas they always defend this
stuff the same way listen Trump's not a
lifelong politician he can't know
everything he's making the right
decisions and that's what actually
matters if you're president you get held
to the same standards as other
presidents and misstating the wars that
other countries have started not knowing
what country's leaders you're even
meeting with these aren't like niche
micro criticisms this is basic stuff
that's truly pathetic and it's not
making America great again this is an
absolute and total embarrassment I have
just genuinely good news for you today
last week I reported to you that in the
midterm elections Republican martha
mcsalley
won against democratic congresswoman
Kyrsten Sinema that has changed since
election night they've been counting
uncounted ballots which you should do if
the ballots are valid and as it turns
out those uncounted ballots were
disproportionately from the blue parts
of Arizona
and cinema took what is now an
insurmountable lead and has defeated
Republican martha mcsalley mcsalley
conceding so republicans will still
control the senate with a majority but
by one fewer or is it one less seat or
one fewer seat than we thought in either
case they're going to have not as many
seats as they believed they were going
to have and very interestingly when it
comes to Kyrsten Sinema specifically
number one the last time that Arizona
even had a democratic senator was in
1995 with Dennis Deacon Cheney and that
that is notable also notable that
Kyrsten Sinema she appears to be the
first US senator elected who formally
says she has no religious affiliation
and we can all sort of understand that
there were there were and are very
likely some senators who are not
actually religious but they still say I
am Christian statistically speaking or
maybe I am Jewish in the case of some so
this is not literally the first
non-religious person but it is the first
senator who formally states that she is
not part of any organized religion and
this is why you've got to fight every
race and count every ballot if we had
accepted pat on election day that this
was it and not continued to push she
might not have won we now have updated
midterm results it's good for Democrats
and this is why we have to make sure
that every single ballot Pat is counted
in Florida because it might not change
the results but it might yeah and
Kyrsten Sinema she's not the most
progressive person out there but hey it
is Arizona after all and I'd rather see
a Democrat when that seats in a
Republican and it looks like the the
Republican majority in the Senate's
gonna be 53 to 47 that makes it slightly
easier for Democrats to take back the
Senate in 2020 that road now becomes a
lot more possible and I want to talk
about in the context of 2020 so last
week when I gave sort of my analysis of
the results which were this was pretty
good for Democrats given the
circumstances
but at the same time I understand
wanting more because we have such an
outrageous administration right now and
I get it when you see this cartoonish
disaster that we have in the White House
right now you think wow if people
understand what's going on we should be
absolutely crushing and we had a
situation where the Senate was stacked
against us
just slightly losing really isn't that
bad when you consider that in the House
Democrats have as of right now picked up
32 seats this may not be the
overwhelming victory some wanted but the
truth is that this is the most seats
that Democrats have picked up in a
midterm election in any election in the
house in a very long time I don't even
remember exactly when when the last time
was that Democrats had plus 32 in an
election in the house but this is a good
result the the Democrats won the popular
vote in the House by five million votes
they won the popular vote in the Senate
by about fourteen million if I recall
correctly and if you account for the
fact that for dianne feinstein's seat
you had two Democrats running you can
take away all of Kevin de león's votes I
think it was about two and a half three
million you still have Democrats
receiving 11 million more votes in
Senate races than Republicans so there
is now a very clear set of goals for
2020 the Senate is going to be tough
even though the map is in some ways
better for Democrats in the Senate in
2020 because Democrats are going to have
more safe seats than Republicans the
Republican seats as Pat pointed out last
week are mostly in some pretty red
states you're almost definitely I think
Pat going to lose Alabama back to
Republicans you had a serial child sex
assault or who only lost by a few points
any reasonable person is Prabhu and by
reasonable I mean not a serial accused
sex assault er Democrats will probably
lose Alabama but there is a path to
controlling the Senate there that is
true Democrats will probably lose
Alabama but hey they can probably beat
Corey go
during Colorado they might be able to be
Joni Ernst in Iowa Thom Tillis he's
vulnerable in North Carolina and Susan
Collins our good old friend from Maine I
think she she could lose that race as
well so the point is you've got to fight
every seat you have to fight for every
vote and until all the votes are
actually counted you aren't done and we
will see what we ultimately hear about
the recounts that are currently taking
place in Florida and that's actually
what I want to talk about next the US
dollar has a pretty privileged position
among world currencies which is good for
the United States because it's a trading
currency it's a reserve currency in many
parts of the world so it's not just
within the United States that the
dollars used it's used by countries all
over the world for transactions between
many other countries forty to forty five
percent of international payments happen
in dollars two-thirds of global reserves
are in dollars two-thirds of physical
dollar bills are outside of the United
States this global reliance on the
dollar keeps interest rates low which is
good for our economy it's really easy to
sell US bonds because a lot of the world
is already operating in dollars and
trading with other countries meaning
imports and exports trading with other
countries is one step easier for the
United States because our currency
happens to be one that's already being
used by many other countries but the
consequences would be bigger than just
these numbers if the United States
dollar were no longer such a prominent
currency we have clout economically
around the world and diplomatically
around the world because of the
prevalence of our currency being used by
different countries the world wants
dollars which makes American exports
worth more this is where we get to the
current administration unfortunately
under Donald Trump under this increased
geopolitical economic diplomatic
instability that has surfaced under
Trump we're seeing the world start to
move away from us
more and more and it is really important
to understand this we might feel as
though obviously the dollar is the
currency of the world
it's nothing fixed or immutable about
that it might seem like dollars are at
the top of the food chain but the reason
for that is a lot of what I've told you
and the fact that the US has been seen
as a sort of stable geopolitical player
that can be trusted to stick to our
agreements to be present in our
alliances that's increasingly in
question and there are two sort of
unrelated ways in which Donald Trump is
causing the self-inflicted demise of the
dollar number one is that the status of
the US around the world as untrustworthy
hurts our credibility this includes
Trump backing out of agreements for no
good reason this includes you know the
Iran deal the Paris climate deal that's
the sort of geopolitical attack on the
dollar that we're seeing then there's
the economic one trumps tariffs for
example buy by virtue of how they impact
our allies push other countries to say
maybe maybe we don't want to be dealing
in the dollar the dollar starts to
become a risk for other countries to
hold rather than a stable mechanism and
then we get to one of the most
interesting aspects of this Donald Trump
has been talking about how the trade
deficit is really a bad thing meaning
when we have a trade deficit we are
importing more than we are exporting or
we are buying more than we're selling
we're consuming more than we are
producing what that means is that we
have to borrow at the country level to
pay for a lot of that stuff that we're
consuming that means more dollars are
going out than dollars coming in that's
why there are all these dollars floating
around the world that other countries
use for transactions and make it easier
for them to use the dollar as their
reserve currency if Trump succeeds in
getting rid of our trade deficit the
number of extra dollars around the world
goes way down which hurts our clout as a
reserve currency
basic economics and very quickly this
starts to get into way more sort of
advanced economics then certainly Trump
can understand but the point is that the
same trade deficit that Donald Trump
claims to want to get rid of to help the
United States would actually be even
more damaging to the US dollar if he did
it he claims to be a nationalist that's
his word if that's the case why is he
advocating a policy that would be bad
for the US dollar the national currency
which I would imagine nationalists would
want to support send me your thoughts on
that we're going to talk more about it
on upcoming programs okay let's talk
about the attacks on democracy that have
been fomented by the Republican Party
we've seen Russian interference in our
elections and a lack of willingness from
Republicans to do a damn thing about it
we've seen voter suppression tactics and
fake stories about voter fraud and three
to five million illegal votes and we've
seen the gutting of the Voting Rights
Act really serious attacks on the
democratic institutions of the United
States and on democracy and voting
itself over the weekend a report from
the Miami New Times was published and it
says that there are a ton of uncounted
ballots from Florida which are just
sitting in a mail handling facility for
miami-dade County which is by the way a
consistently democratic voting county in
Florida the specific details are still
blurry it's not totally clear why the
ballots were just sitting at the mail
handling facility it's not clear exactly
when they were postmarked which would
determine whether they're eligible to be
counted or not it's unclear whether they
were delayed because the mag a bomber
was actually sent a pipe bomb through
this facility the facility was evacuated
and is that may be responsible for the
delay we don't know but what we do know
is that these ballots could conceivably
have impacted the Florida gubernatorial
race between
Democratic candidate Andrew Gilliam and
Republican Ron De Santis these held up
ballots from a very blue part of Florida
could have impacted the Senate race
between Republican Rick Scott and
incumbent Democrat Bill Nelson so as all
this is going on Donald Trump says that
the counting of these ballots is voter
fraud he tries to be clever but he
actually sounds very ignorant on Twitter
when he says quote you mean they are
just now finding votes in Florida and
Georgia but the election was on Tuesday
let's blame the Russians and demand an
immediate apology from President Putin
there is no evidence whatsoever that
these ballots were forged or that any
ballots were forged Donald Trump here is
lying without evidence about the
integrity of our elections this is far
more dangerous than lying about the
number of people that attended his
inauguration these are lies meant to
give people false beliefs about the
integrity of one of the most important
democratic systems we have in the
country that of voting and it wasn't
just Trump because then Sean Hannity on
Fox News interviews the Republican
candidate Rick Scott who is also Florida
Governor and Hannity says someone should
be in jail for the ballot counting and
if you're watching this clip you'll
notice that Governor Rick Scott nods
agreeing with Hannity yes someone should
be in jail for counting people's ballots
take a look at this I've never seen
anything like this in my life
it is obviously corrupt obviously laws
were broken obviously their shenanigans
here I believe you and senator Rubio are
100% correct we will follow this every
single second of every day now yeah
because the people of Florida deserve
their just vote which they got it and
you won this race hands down and this is
a this is a disgrace that they get to do
this election an election out somebody
needs to go to jail here if this keeps
happening you keep violating the law you
don't respond every other County risk
Bonz someone needs to go to jail says
Sean Hannity and Rick Scott just nods so
what do they claim is so wrong with
what's going on well they're saying that
finding these ballots is the scam that
once the democrats realized they lost
these two races in florida they found
these bogus fake fraudulent ballots
don't you think that if anyone was
actually planning to turn the election
with the bags full of fake paper ballots
they would have figured out a way pat to
get those ballots in before Election Day
since usually ballots are only counted
before Election Day like every
allegation of voter fraud from the right
assumes everybody is stupid they claim
that people are swinging elections by
doing in person voter fraud that
individuals are showing up at polling
places and voting twice or voting as
dead people or as people that aren't
actually them that would be such a
stupid way to steal an election and
likewise the idea that Democrats planted
countless fake paper ballots enough to
swing the election but they were stupid
enough to wait until after the election
was over to claim that those ballots
exist you've got to be incredibly
incompetent at trying to steal elections
if this is what you're doing
yeah it's a totally fair argument to say
that it's Monday we shouldn't be still
counting votes that were cast from last
Tuesday I mean we should just know the
results within 24 hours or so of the
election that's all well and good
because I think it can undermine their
confidence in our electoral system but
what's not justice justifiable is to say
that well these boats are coming in
later so therefore we just have to usurp
the will of the people and that these
boats are just not gonna get counted
that's not the right way out of this yes
and there are very clear rules about the
postmark dates and all sorts of other
stuff like we can very easily figure
this thing out and that's actually I
want to talk to the reasonable people in
the audience for a second if you are
reasonable you probably have the view
that we should be able to put political
disagreements aside and just work
together
and figure out a simple way to make sure
that there's a fair and equal standard
so that everybody who is legally able to
vote and votes is sure that their vote
is counted and that nobody is scared
away from voting legally and you would
be right we should be able to do that
the reason we can't is that one party
benefits from a lower voter turnout
that's the Republican Party that's why
we can't fix it because one party and
one political movement the American
right wing they don't want higher
turnout it's bad for their candidates
it's in one party's favor for everybody
to vote and it's in the other party's
favor for people not to vote voting
itself is now partisan and we're really
screwed if we can't figure that out and
solve that problem and and unfortunately
I'm scared we can't because the
incentives are really clear and the
stakes are too high the right can't
allow everybody to vote because they
will get crushed and that's why we have
this situation okay so let's continue
our analysis and discussion of the
firing de-facto firing the forced
resignation of Jeff Sessions and the
bringing in of Matthew Whitaker who is
unconstitutionally inserted by Donald
Trump and causing all sorts of chaos
involving both left wing and right wing
legal scholars saying you can't do this
you simply cannot do this many many
problems with Matthew Whitaker he's in
the tank on Russia there's been this op
IDI that he wrote which now has been
scrutinized he wrote it on CNN saying
that the molar probe is wrong and it's
bad and that he would end it by starving
it of funds the appointment itself
unconstitutional as I said and we now
have learned that back in 2014 he
actually ran for the Republican Iowa
u.s. senator from Iowa Republican
nomination back in 2014 and Matthew
Whittaker said that judges without a New
Testament biblical view of justice
shouldn't serve on the federal bench and
he even went as far as to suggest that
he'd try to prevent
non-christian judges from being
appointed to the bench if he got a
chance and he is very close to getting
that chance right now back when he was
running for that Republican nomination
in Iowa he attended a forum that was
hosted by the religious right group the
family leader and a lot of crazy ideas
as you can probably imagine were floated
at that forum including using god-given
natural law to decide who would make
good judges Whitaker went even beyond
that prepare yourself to be disgusted
during this forum Matthew Whitaker said
while I agree that I want to understand
their judicial philosophy and whether
they understand natural law and natural
rights and then the founding documents
and how they fit together I don't think
that gets us far enough because natural
law oftentimes is used from the eye of
the beholder what I'd like to see is
things like their worldview are they
people of faith do they have a biblical
view of justice I think that is very
important and the moderator interjected
Levitical or New Testament this is code
for are Jews allowed Levitical biblical
code would would include Jews because
it's Old Testament New Testament would
also exclude Jews and Matthew Whittaker
said I'm a New Testament and what I know
is as long as they have that New
Testament worldview that they'll be a
good judge later in this same forum he
also mentioned he would be extra
concerned about atheists being judges
saying quote if they have a secular
worldview then I'm going to be very
concerned about how they judge this is
against the Constitution of the United
States which says no religious test
shall ever be required as a
qualification to any office or public
trust under the United States this is
against the stated mission of the
Justice Department this is against
everything that the United States is
supposed to be and this is what the
top law enforcer of the United States
believes this is his version this is a
Christian version of Sharia law and we
find so often Pat that it's okay for
there to be no separation of church and
state as long as it's their religion but
as soon as someone wants to swear on a
Koran or doesn't believe in God they
should not be allowed and this is so
dangerous and it just has to be stopped
I don't know how else to say it Pat
right Matt what occur could be more
backwards and bigoted than even the last
Attorney General Jeff Sessions
even though sessions is someone who said
that he thinks the ACLU and the
n-double-a-cp are unamerican
and that they tried to force civil
rights down our throats we've mentioned
over and over the comments about how he
used to like the KKK before they started
smoking pot all that stuff is bad
Whitaker could end up topping that this
is how we return to the Dark Ages quite
frankly and why the developed world is
laughing at us which we're going to talk
about in the next in the next show
that's that's a piece I'm working on
this stuff is more in line with what
happens in the countries that many
Americans claim we are better than a lot
of the countries where you have people
on the right saying we can't allow them
to come here
because we are just so superior to them
in every way this is what they say not
what I say this is the type of stuff
that goes on in those countries and in
addition a company that Whitaker was
involved with as an adviser is under FBI
investigation they're they're putting in
charge of the FBI a guy who has been
advising a company that is being
investigated by the FBI the company is
called world Patent marketing Whitaker
was on the Advisory Board they are under
potential criminal investigation by the
FBI right now this must be stopped
this absolutely has to be stopped and
you know that this is starting to get to
the White House and Donald Trump because
Trump is now going into talking point
komuz denying he even knows Matthew
Whitaker and those are the clips I want
to get to next